anthony fauci has announced his
resignation and he announced it early
about a month ago he said he was going
to resign at the end of joe biden's
first term
now he's going to be resigning in
december he says he's not retiring
though he's going to keep working just
you know not in government republicans
have responded that this is a lot to do
with potential investigations coming
after the midterm elections and i think
that's probably right now we actually
struggled with what to lead with i think
you know fauci announcing his
resignation
what is this oh that might be coming
from me is it ian did you hear that ian
what are you doing i'm an animal i'm
working
the show the youtube's screwing up on
frying eggs ian turns his volume all the
way up
all right so we were actually struggling
with um uh which story to lead with
because there's another story
two bombs were planted in west virginia
one at a federal courthouse and one at a
church the bomb squad showed up and
detonated the device in the federal
courthouse we don't know uh we don't
know exactly why or what happened
there's some other news too donald trump
is suing to block the fbi from reviewing
seized materials according to
some people who worked in the trump
administration they believe that these
materials are related to the russia gate
investigation which makes a lot of sense
and we've also seen reporting that the
fbi group that went after these
documents was the same group that
actually led the russia collusion fbi
investigation so it sounds like things
are pretty corrupt across the board we
got a lot of stuff to talk about this is
crazy plus the the assassination of
alexander dugan's daughter
man what a monday i guess wow before we
get started my friends head over to
timcast.com
become a member if you'd like to support
our work we are going to have a members
only show coming up for you at 11 p.m
and this one's going to be very good
we're going to get in deep details about
covet and vaccines because uh so first
let me say
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and the after show is gonna be
particularly important because we are
being joined by the surgeon general of
florida joe ladopo thank you i'm very
happy to be here with you tonight so do
you want to give a brief introduction on
who you are what you do
yeah sure my name is joe latapo i am the
surgeon general of florida prior to that
i was a professor at ucla and prior to
that i was a professor at uc at nyu
and i'm a physician i'm a researcher i
have a background in in research and i
mostly did research and i took care of
patients at ucla ronald reagan hospital
in west los angeles and i've enjoyed my
position as the surgeon general of
florida
and you know we'll we'll talk more about
some medical health health issues at
some point i think perfect timing i mean
we we book you and then fauci announces
he's resigning he may have resigned
because you but that's right that's
right
the temperature has gotten getting
warmer when uh when joe walked in i'm
like my wrist was kind of screwed up
cause i was skating so you know and then
he's like let me see actually as a
doctor take a look at my wrist so this
guy's a real doctor uh glad you could be
here tim promised not to sue
you know i told him
well you know all right
glad you're here we also have hannah
claire bremelo hi i'm hannah claire
brimlow i'm a writer for timcast.com
that's it what's up everybody ian
crossland here happy to be here good to
see you let's get rolling we also got
chris poole hi i'm chris
lydia's not on vacation she's getting is
wait is it public why she's off yeah she
posted it oh okay she's got surgery i'm
like wait am i gonna announce that she's
getting surgery and no one knows getting
a wrist fix yeah see i fell and hurt my
wrist and i ignored it and now it's like
a month later and it's still messed up
but i'm like whatever i can still use i
can still type and play the guitar and
everything and the the doctor over here
took a look at it and it seems okay
right
did i did i stay ready that he promised
not to sue if i miss diagnosis yeah you
know tim should have he should probably
have a brace he should probably get some
physical therapy um um you guys need to
tell his mom so that you know she wants
to make him do it so joanne fired up i
think lydia did the more responsible
things you went to the doctor and they
were like we need to give you surgery
and then i'm just kind of like what just
kind of pops up when you investigated
his wrist what was it was a little like
swollen tender what'd you what'd you
notice he doesn't have any swelling but
he's got some laxness in in some of his
wrist joints and he probably just needs
to kind of have it immobilized so really
um that that's probably playing the
guitar and everything before you know
yeah
joe doesn't like that answer you know
you're not you're not arthritic when
you're
when you're a little bit you know hey
we got a music video coming out on
friday so yeah now's not the time to
immobilize my wrists what are you so i'm
going to talk harder submerge it and let
it just float in the tub does that help
you you can be like a doctor and be a
bad patient so you can you can wear the
wrist brace and then take it off to play
guitar and skateboard
and then when you come into the doctor's
office say that you've been adherent
actually that's how doctors are i put
the wrist brace on when i am skate
skating okay yeah so i was skateboarding
earlier and i was i always wear the
wrist guard and actually fell on it and
i'm glad i was wearing the wrist card
okay oh nice yeah and then when i'm
doing the you know when i'm doing the
bigger ramps now i started wearing a
helmet because i started thinking about
it and i'm like i've never hit my head
in my life
but it would kind of suck for everybody
who worked here if i hit my head and
they lost their jobs so i'm like yes i'm
really opposed to this i would
personally like it if you wore a helmet
every time me and your mom are like tim
put a helmet on
my mom's like my son's in danger and
hannah close like my job's in danger no
no i mean i don't want you to get hurt
but also like i like working at this
super cool news site called gas.com i
kind of need you to be there let's jump
to this first story from the national
review
anthony fauci plans to step down in
december that's it he wrote a big long
thing saying i will be leaving these
positions in december of this year to
pursue the next chapter of my career
he's 81
what's the next chapter of your career i
mean i'm trying to be a dick or anything
but it's like bro get your rocking chair
sit on your porch rock back and forth
with a nice sweet tea and enjoy and
enjoy your sunny days man but he's
saying he's still got a lot to do
now the the big thing here is let me see
if i have it pulled up
newsweek writes fauci resigning out of
fear of gop investigations say
republicans
in december fauci will forfeit his roles
as the chief of the niaid laboratory of
immuno regulation and president joe
biden's chief medical advisor saying he
wants to pursue the next chapter of my
career republicans believe fauci is
leaving government due to the
possibility that the gop will take
control of the house in november
dr fauci is conveniently resigning from
his position in december before house
republicans have an opportunity to hold
him accountable for destroying our
country over these past three years the
republican rep andy biggs of arizona
tweeted
adding that fauci will be held
accountable whether or not he remains in
public office this guy is a coward well
maybe that's the case but if he's not
actively in government and they start
investigating him it won't disrupt
whatever those those uh institutions are
actually doing so
either way
this is this move will absolutely help
joe biden's administration over the next
couple of years and the nia niaid but
i'm curious uh joe considering you're
actually i mean surgeon general you're
like the top doctor of florida right as
crazy as it sounds i mean i have to
pinch myself i am literally the top
doctor of florida which is kind of nuts
well what do you think about this you
think his resignation is just career
stuff uh what do you think about fauci
well you know
i think dr falchi is a
creepy guy he's totally honest he gives
me the creeps
you know i think that
he's you know he he's he is
enigmatic of a of a
physician who
is really more of a politician
and more
about
you know sort of agendas
than about health i mean that's been
very obvious with how he handled the
pandemic not a single word right you
have a condition where obesity is a
major risk factor did he ever say hey
americans by the way you know lose
weight if you're overweight get some
exercise i didn't hear that out of his
health he did want to say vitamin d
though
he did say vitamin d is important he did
say that once and he said that once
never again
right yeah right that is that is the
creepiest thing to me about a lot of
this uh is that
during the pandemic people had had
pointed out quite extensively vitamin d
you know getting sunlight getting
exercise getting fresh air and these
things were really important but this
was never the official guidance it was
never the narrative in fact was quite
the opposite stay inside don't go
outside in big cities they locked
everybody in their homes yeah no
absolutely
and you know there's some controversy
over vitamin d but it's not killing
anyone so
it was the right thing to do what's the
vitamin d controversy well it's you know
vitamin d is very mysterious because
there is study after study that shows
that if you have low levels of vitamin d
you're at higher risk for everything
depression high blood pressure cancer i
mean you name it infection
but the clinical trials have not usually
shown
what the other studies have shown
not all of them though some of them have
shown a reduction in infection actually
with vitamin d pre-pandemic
but it again it's it's very interesting
the studies go both ways and
what what gets me actually is that
you know
maybe it doesn't work but there's like
there's a class of doctors who are just
rabid about
trying to stop people from using
medications that are low risk and you
know and are uncertain they're just they
just want to keep saying no that doesn't
work no that doesn't work there's
actually
i don't want to get too nerdy but
fluvoxamine is a medication that had a
couple clinical trials that showed
benefit in covid and i i recommended it
you know i recommended it to patients
because there was data
but you know another trial just came out
that didn't find a benefit and
the jury the writers at the new england
journal medicine slammed this medication
but the problem is the medication was
dosed at like 50
of the dose that worked
so how can you slam how can you conclude
that something doesn't work when you're
not even dosing it right but they're
just crazy about concluding things don't
work and telling people not to use stuff
what was what was the one you just
mentioned
fluoroxamine fluvoxamine what is that
actually it's it's a medication for like
anxiety
and it just so happens that one of the
ways it works
is on a receptor that is also needed by
the virus so a few clinical trials have
shown that it it benefits people but so
this is not an official treatment it's
not approved or anything like that it's
not an official treatment the fda
actually reviewed it recently and they
decided not to give it the thumbs up
and you know that was criticized by some
advocates of the of the medication and
you know the fda it wasn't that they
didn't make the right decision but they
took forever to make the decision and
this thing we could have had the answer
to this like two years ago literally but
there was you know there was very little
interest in treatment during the
pandemic as well i think people know
there's there's there's several
treatments that um have become you know
notorious
and
youtube explicitly bans people for for
uh advocating for and things like that
the strange thing to me about a lot of
it is
if if the argument was always talk to
your doctor
why is it that if if a doctor recommends
something publicly it's it's
unacceptable and it's bannable look i i
understand this there will there's a lot
of crazy people saying a lot of crazy
things online and i can understand
there's a fear that during a pandemic
someone's telling you to do something
wacky or wild and you know they wanna
they wanna control that but you can't
that's that's the thing like you
literally can't you've got a bunch of
doctors who are like i'm a doctor here's
what i recommend and they're like you're
banned and it's like but fauci's not
practicing is that correct like he
wasn't practicing for 30 years
i don't think he still sees patients
certainly not actively or frequently
so the the issue i take with fauci over
the past several years um notably during
the peak of the pandemic was the the
wishy-washiness the flip-flopping yeah
which which he justified as well the
science is changing oh gosh he didn't
justify anything that guy i mean he's so
slippery and slick i he just
he's completely dishonest it's ironic
that so many americans trust him and he
is probably one of the least trustworthy
doctors i've ever you know observed in
my life but he's not even my
understanding not practicing for a very
very long time he's a bureaucrat more
than anything oh that's for sure but
he's coming off on tv as if he is the
expert and because of the things he says
you end up with these really weird
tribalist positions where very famously
early on he said don't wear masks later
on he said the reason they were saying
that is because they needed the masks
for the nurses and the doctors and it
was more important they got it and it
was like so which is it
you know were you did the science change
or were you aware and you didn't want
people buying masks either way you cut
it all right he's dishonest
by the way the science didn't change but
either way you cut it he's dishonest
because the thing is the clinical trials
before the pandemic almost all of them
found no benefit from regular folks
walking around with masks i'm not
talking about hospitals i'm talking
about walking around the city like you
see you're going the grocery store
wearing a mask so that's what the
studies showed so the rationale behind
but that wasn't flipping
then why did he change his position
that's a great question i mean you know
he what he said of course was that he
was trying to save the masks for
healthcare workers but how can you even
believe i mean it's hard to well so i'll
say this uh we we've had we've had
conversations about masks before um
we're outside of all of this pandemic
stuff now so i don't know where any of
like youtube's policies sit on this
stuff but uh we've pulled up the cdc's
website and it actually
it's not as crazy as a lot of you know
there's there's the pro-mass people and
the anti-mess people it's actually
decently
i mean moderate when it comes to masks
like the cdc said there's a marginal
benefit it's decent enough that they
would recommend it in some circumstances
like the obvious thing i would say you
know obviously if you're sick and you're
wearing a mask you're going to stop some
coughing sneezing and spitting on people
and something like that right sure
but that's different from whether
wearing a mask reduces the chance of
someone else getting a virus
and even you know i get it like the idea
that you think something's going to work
and therefore it should work but that's
why we have clinical studies right well
but the cdc on the website now says that
there was a moderate reduction in like
70 different studies this is the last
time we pulled up this huge list of
studies there yeah i know and this so
this is this is dishonest science
because what you know i i mentioned
vitamin d earlier right so you've got
your observational studies that always
find a relationship where the low levels
and bad health outcomes and then you've
got your clinical trials that
unfortunately most of the time haven't
found a benefit
the same thing goes for masks they pull
up these observational studies and they
hang their hats on them and the
observational studies are finding these
huge reductions and they and then they
say oh look at this the masks work great
you know and and make those you know
everyone should wear them including kids
like the most ridiculous part i've got
little kids myself
but then you look at the we did there
were during the pandemic there were at
least two large clinical trials one
found zip zero no benefit the second one
was found was it was it was a denmark
pardon was that also an observational
stuff no no this was a clinical trial
like this is you know you randomize
people you give you know and you you
that's that's the gold standard for
testing stuff whether something actually
works
that's how you know if it really works
and it should work in a clinical trial
too
and one study found zero no benefit
there was so much spin by the way when
that study came out by medical doctors
trying to explain why there wasn't a
benefit
the second study basically found no
benefit there was no benefit for a cloth
mask zero none whatsoever for surgical
mass there was like a ten percent
reduction so you know twelve percent
versus eleven percent of people tested
positive like this is the thing that
they're letting people fight over in
airports about and then for young people
there was zero benefit whatsoever in the
second study so it's a it's a it's a big
lie i mean they're not it's not like
they don't know what evidence is that's
what evidence is well so let me let me
pull up this from uh los angeles daily
news mask mandate didn't work against
covet 19 in l.a say doctors from usc and
ucla letter from doctors said masking
had limited effect and it's best to
stress vaccines other doctors still back
masks i think that the one of the
biggest problems we have right now is uh
youtube censorship policies
what i mean how do you even have a
conversation on science if science
changes if you're not allowed to discuss
science changing dr fauci came out early
on and said not to wear masks he then
came back later and said okay now we're
masks now we have usc and ucla saying
the mandates didn't actually do anything
to stop this so my question is
how can youtube set a censorship policy
when ucla and usc has has issued these
statements like this right i mean it's
it's an untenable situation you can't
even have a public conversation about
how how are we supposed to address any
of this stuff how are we supposed to
function as a society
if that is how big tech is handling it i
totally agree with you you know their
agenda seems
it seems more political from my
perspective from everything i've seen
and you know and i mean i think it's a
pretty rotten system i think it's hurt
people
you know it's not a business that's
going very well for them in terms of
regulating knowledge and opinions well
so where does fuji go from here what do
you guys think
when i came in i said you know what what
the the number one indication that of
why someone is resigning is because they
failed i don't know if that's why he's
resigning because he he's now admitting
defeat and failure if he's realized i've
come to the point in my career where i
can no longer serve i'm resigning like
doing the right thing maybe he's doing
the right thing you probably write a
book
i think he could do any number of things
he is entitled to i think the largest
retirement pack package in federal
history because he's the highest paid
federal government employee uh that's
like a study from open the books or a
report from open the books in december
of 2021 i covered it for our site um so
in some ways it is interesting to me
that he is not opting to retire because
he'd still make a lot of money off of
retiring in some ways to me it's hard
not to read vanity into this retiring
means that you're old and retiring means
that you like are no longer supposed to
have an opinion and right now he wields
a lot of influence so if he retires he
is acting as if he's going to step back
and he doesn't want to i mean this is
the man who while by the pandemic filmed
a
documentary about himself with disney
it's a
it doesn't seem like he knows where he
wants to go but he does not want to
leave the limelight and of course that's
subjective although
retiring does seem like a totally
plausible option for him he did i think
i was talking about this before the show
uh in july there was this report from
politico he'd done this interview and
politico reported that fauci intended to
retire at the end of biden's
administration so that would be next
december not this one and then the day
after they published he was like no i'm
not going to retire what do you mean i
didn't say that even though they have
him on record saying that so it seems
like again this idea of retiring
has a lot of fear for him and whether
it's because he thinks he opens the door
for an investigation or if it's a vanity
it's hard to say are you saying that he
could have stayed at the job longer and
then retired and got a monetary package
but yeah he's entitled to a government
pension and because he's been working
for the federal government for i think
four decades uh it's very sizable and
even though he's resigning is he still
getting the same package i believe he
still has access to it but again he's
not publicly retiring and to me that
speaks to vanity he doesn't want to seem
like the old out of touch doctor i wanna
i wanna i wanna ask real quick i don't
wanna stick around on this subject too
much but i pulled up the cdc.gov and
they they mentioned so explain to me
what these studies mean it says a large
this is from the cdc the cdc still
recommends wearing masks if you're going
to be in large gatherings this is a
large well-designed cluster randomized
trial in bangladesh in late 2020 found
that surgical or cloth mask mask
distribution
role modeling and active mass promotion
tripled the mass use by 42.3 percent in
intervention villages compared to 13
in villages receiving mask interventions
symptomatic cerro provelance of sarskova
ii was reduced by approximately nine
percent relative to comparison villages
in villages randomized to receive
surgical masks symptomatic
sero-prevalence of soros coveted two was
significantly lower 11.1 percent overall
the results of the study show that even
modest increases in community use can
effectively reduce symptomatic sars
coveted to infections
so
that that sounds like they do you know
like i was saying you know the cdc says
it's marginal nine to ten percent i mean
that's good though right
so that's not good like so
so that nine or ten percent so the
serial prevalence that they mentioned
what does that mean by the way serial
prevalence so they test people's blood
for antibodies to the virus
as an indicator of prior infection
right
so
so nine or ten percent that's called
eight that's a relative reduction so if
you have
the villages that get the the villages
that get the masks
and their cereal prevalences is 12
percent and you have the villages that
don't get the masks and their zero
prevalence is 11 percent that's a 10
reduction
oh 10 of 12 is one yeah
right that's some lazy that's something
so that is what happened
that's what happened and that by the way
is just another just that's just an
example of the of why you know doctors
like
myself and i think probably some of the
other doctors you've had on your show
are just are are just
fed up with the lies and the
misrepresentation of science that is
exactly what happens you're familiar
with the study you're saying oh yeah
that's that's the second clinical trial
that i mentioned that's so this is not
what the cdc says though i mean well
they're saying that you went from 12 to
11
and that was a significant that shows
that it makes a big difference because
it doesn't mention the 12 percent it
just says that
uh covid
ser provence was in villages with masks
was reduced by nine percent and villages
randomized to receive surgical masks it
was down 11.1 percent
right
right so that's a relative reduction and
i just happen to remember from reading
the study that the cereal prevalence it
was in the teens right so there was like
a one percentage point difference
in the prevalence that's a fact i mean
that's what that exactly yeah because it
sounds like it's going from 22 percent
hold on hold on even gets worse this is
funny it sounds like you're saying masks
work
well actually gets worse than that so we
have a threshold
in
health policy and epidemiology and
statistics for when we consider a
difference as being significant
you know it's kind of arbitrary but
that's how things work so that threshold
in that study like if this is a
threshold right say we were checking you
know say we were testing the effective
exercise on
heart disease right
you know if this is a threshold you
compare people that exercise people who
don't like you're like way below the
threshold it clearly is beneficial for
health the threshold for that study was
right here
it was barely significant
they were they'd they barely reached
significance i mean that is an extremely
weak finding well i can only i can only
say that you know the cdc
still has on their website the
recommendation and several studies but i
don't know how to reconcile that with
the newsguard certified los angeles
daily news saying that scientists
doctors from usc and ucla saying that
the masks uh that mask masking had a
limited effect it sounds like they're
saying more in line with what you're
saying in fact you were at ucla i
believe i was at ucla and what they're
saying is factual
based on the data maybe they work a lot
better but that hasn't been shown from
clinical trials is there uh evidence
that if you have a dirty mask with like
fecal mech like just gross up that and
you breathe it in that it'll make you
sick
bacteria let's talk about it
well if you have fecal stuff on your
mask you probably will get sick
halitosis
well you know the actually there are
some studies that show some evidence of
of harm potential harm
you know they don't get a lot of they
don't get any media attention but there
are some studies that show harm in fact
there was a clinical trial of cloth
masks among doctors healthcare workers
in thailand i think it was thailand that
was published years ago in the british
medical journal which is a very good
journal they compared cloth masks to
surgical masks and basically the people
in this cloth mask group got more
infections
like it seemed that something about it
seemed to increase their is it is it is
it fair to say though you gotta be
careful about like a single study that
comes out you know you want to see it
the the test like you want to see the
results absolutely in science absolutely
absolutely you mentioned observational
studies how do those work exactly
relative to like a clinical trial well
clinical trial is great because you you
bring people in and you say that okay
these people they're going to get the
intervention these people are not and
you kind of you follow them and you see
what happens i mean that's the gold
standard
observational studies you know you go
around this room and you measure let's
say you measure um
you know what's a good one for this room
uh
sugar consumption
let's do it yeah okay so you measure
sugar consumption and you have each one
of us go out and skateboard okay
so
you know i i i don't know let's suppose
that i don't drink i don't have much
sugar consumption lower energy drink
consumption okay
so you so you got guys like me who
basically don't consume energy drinks
say one of you guys do and let's say
that tim consumes a lot of energy drinks
and then you like you go and see how
well we skateboard or we feel some
survey that says how well we skateboard
and then you conclude that hey look at
that you drink more energy drinks you're
going to be a better skateboarder that's
how observational studies work so
they're not they're not like taking into
account he might have been practicing
skateboarding right
and therefore with that you have
different quality studies like something
that might be better so i think you know
with observational studies you would
need substantially more and all you'd
really do it sounds like is find
anomalies find things that may be that
you'd want to test further that's
exactly right you have to be very very
careful yeah very very careful i mean
the
there's so many examples of
misdirection from observational studies
in regards to vitamin d which we brought
up earlier is there a difference i've
heard there's a difference in endogenous
vitamin d and vitamin d that you take
meaning the the vitamin d you get your
body to produce naturally from like
sunlight causing it to happen as opposed
to eating a vitamin d
vitamin is there a difference in the way
it biochemically interacts
so
you know
biochemically not sure i mean the
process by which they it's you know when
your body creates vitamin d versus
taking it from a pill i mean that is
different biologically
but you know in terms of things like if
you break your wrist or something and
it's because you you've got you know low
bone density
whether you take supplemental vitamin d
or you get more sunlight
the benefits of the vitamin d to your
bones are going to be the same
but there are people who believe that
there are differences in the effects
from whether it's sunlight or from a
pill i don't know that science well
enough we're gonna we're gonna do a like
very hard segue because they call that
jerk let's just jerk brace yourself
yourselves
the subject is changing so hard
the next story we have because
i'll just mention this for everybody
we're gonna get into way more detail on
all of this stuff at timcast.com the 11
pm members only show for a variety of
reasons some of them are fairly obvious
but we're going to get into a lot of
deep details especially with florida's
response and what florida's doing and
then we've got some other stuff i want
to talk about when it comes to medical
practices in florida pertaining to trans
kids but we do have some some breaking
news that we we put off for a little bit
we have this story from metro news west
virginia explosive devices reported at
two locations in blue field
there were no injuries of the discovery
of two explosive devices in bluefield on
monday morning west virginia state
police the bluefield police department
and other law enforcement responded to a
call at the federal courthouse in
downtown bluefield around 9 40 a.m
officers evacuated all people from the
building
and an adjacent department building as
they dealt with the device apparently
they detonated police yell fire in the
hole
before a loud boom was heard it was
destroyed around 11 40 inside the
federal building an explosion was heard
from the building another device was
found at uh i believe it's down here
westminster presbyterian church in
bluefield west virginia bomb squad has
arrived so uh the reason i thought this
was you know this this story caught my
eye and it's not really getting a lot of
attention is someone put in a bomb at a
federal courthouse
i mean we saw in in 2020 the riots with
the far left they were attacking the
federal courthouse in portland
and then i saw it was west virginia and
west virginia's maga country you know
it's it's the second most trump
supporting state in the united states so
i wondered who or why would someone do
this entirely possible it's an isolated
incident pertaining to local matters and
it's only getting national attention
because of the tensions and the
conflicts been happening at the federal
level or with the fbi for instance so we
don't know for sure
uh entirely could be local conflict
uh or it could be
i mean
i'll just i'll just throw it out to you
guys
what political ideology would attack a
federal courthouse at a church
well i've been on high alert since
dugan's daughter we might talk about
this more later that's the next one okay
his daughter was killed in a car bomb so
there's this bombing theme in the last
five days all of a sudden i'm very
concerned about false flags this could
have been
someone from another country that wants
to instill agitation in the in the
people's minds i and that it's a church
and a courthouse like i think two
different buildings about a mile apart
yeah like you don't have far right
religious zealots bombing churches ever
really i mean it is so that doesn't make
it doesn't seem like uh
i am very hesitant to start blaming
groups or ideologies for this because it
could be anybody that wants to see chaos
in the united states could be doing
stuff of war man yuri besmanov yeah i i
remember in the 1970s there were a lot
of environmentalist extremists who
bombed federal buildings or uh federal
lands the
there is a suspect in custody he's uh
his name's dean fabilier he's 50 years
old there's not i haven't had a chance
to look into him too intensely i mean
there is
the instinct and i hesitate to tie it to
any specific group although it's
incredibly disruptive
um but there's also a chance someone had
something personal i was saying before
the show that i wonder what uh what was
on the docket in the courthouse that day
and we looked it up the church and the
uh federal building are about a mile
apart so there's a question of like why
those two places because
this
or he knows a lawyer who was practicing
and he's mad at the priest down the
street like it's very hard to tell
without a ton of information
first and foremost the most important
thing it it's it's it's small town west
virginia so
strong possibility
guy you know
the priest and his neighbor got into a
fight they have a court hearing for some
reason i don't know it's a federal court
so that doesn't make sense actually yeah
there's no reason why a local dispute
would go to a federal court it could be
someone from outside the state would
dispute this guy who's being sued
interstate so it's federal
that's possible but i gotta say
the memes i'll i see all right now are
roe v wade
the federal courts the supreme court the
the federal court of this country the
big one
why would someone go after a church in a
federal court
simple solution hypothesis not saying we
have any evidence of this is is
left-wing
yeah i mean it's typically not
well i don't know
i don't know it's it's scary stuff
considering the escalation we've seen
around the world and the united states
my first thought was when uh
the news broke there was a federal
courthouse that they were going to start
saying it was trump supporters because
of the fbi because they're going after
trump and because this judge this this
uh this federal judge in florida is an
epstein lawyer i don't know if you're
familiar with this guy right yeah i mean
you know i've read the stories yeah and
so i was thinking like maybe this is you
know like that guy in ohio but then they
found okay they said we found we found
one at a church and i'm like okay now
that doesn't make sense like a trump
supporter is not going to put a bomb in
a church that's that they donate to the
church you know if they're gonna do
anything right and so then i saw you
know i saw these memes on facebook and
they're calling it rovember they're
saying rovember roe v wade november go
out and vote november democrats roe v
wade the federal courts the churches the
religious people and i'm wondering if
this is just
more likely to be at the very least not
saying we have evidence but left-wing
radicalization and and attacks
why would it happen in literal manga
country though it's just it's just weird
i mean it's a sign of uh disruption west
virginia is such an interesting state
because it does have such a tie to the
democratic party it was a democratic
stronghold for a long long time and so i
think that native west virginians while
they are often maga supporting
it's a more complex state than people
give it credit for because they
ultimately
like every county in the state went for
trump um i do say like it's very hard to
tell i wouldn't be surprised at all if
this had uh left-wing ties and again i
would really like to know what was going
on in the courthouse today the church is
what's interesting to me because it
feels more personal again a mile away a
20-minute walk that means that you could
have probably i mean it's west virginia
there are probably four other churches
within the vicinity why the presbyterian
one why that one specifically and again
that goes back to it being specific to
that community you want to look you can
look yeah no i mean this is the thing i
can't reconcile right a a local dispute
with a local church but a federal
courthouse there wouldn't be a suit at
the federal courthouse maybe uh the
somewhere the church ratted out a guy
and it's it's a criminal matter i
honestly don't know they said that the
suspect who's in custody is going to
undergo evaluation so they might be
arguing that there's some sort of
psychological disturbance like but again
this is a anybody who's putting a bomb
anywhere a functioning bomb they had to
detonate this system they didn't go in
and say like oh this doesn't work or
it's fake like they had to destroy it is
there knowledge about what the explosive
was sometimes that can help you discern
who did it they didn't say i haven't
seen anything but obviously there's a
reason why
i bring this up
civil war
right
is this uh you know how how old are you
uh joe can i i am you can ask you don't
seem to ask
i'm 43 years old
are you really yeah oh okay you look so
much 79 baby
birthday yeah
what month
i was born in december okay
i was talking to a guy who was in his
60s and he said that he was just a
couple years shy of getting drafted into
vietnam
and then i said so you saw the news
reports about the weather underground
and he's like oh yeah and then i was
like is it worse now or was it worse
then he says way worse now
you can't believe it that's the media a
lot of it is because of the media
because one bomb in central you know
west virginia now is global note like
notoriety whereas in the 70s it was like
good luck if you read about in the paper
the next day maybe it was more regional
and that could be it and that's one of
the things he pointed out he said the
issue is that everything's instantaneous
these days you know back then something
would happen it would take a while for
people to find out about it and react to
it whether that's an escalation or just
you know generally learning about it and
so i think that's the important point in
the 70s with weather underground
something happens when did you learn it
happened right
three days later maybe it happens on a
friday you don't watch the news until
monday and the monday news report comes
out you're like huh today it's the
moment it happens the moment this story
hit
like i'm i'm seeing it i mean granted
it's my job but for people who are on
twitter you're learning about it right
away
i think that actually does mean it's
worse though you know why
if it took a week i mean you go back to
the revolutionary period if it took a
month or two months for someone in a
different state to find out that someone
got shot in a different state they could
not react to it or escalate because they
didn't know it happened but now with
social media and with instant
communications the moment it happens you
see a protest right like you get a video
of a dude being beaten by cops hour
later black lives matter is out on the
street protesting that wasn't that would
be possible without the internet without
cell phones
before before even before um
even when we had cell phones that
wouldn't have happened it was only after
the iphone made it possible for people
to pull up facebook and see community
organizing instantly did we start seeing
that kind of phenomenon phenomenon so
it could be 2007
some cop beats a guy
protests don't show up until the next
day because people go home get on the
computer then learn about it then show
up the next day today
mass tax texts go out so i'm wondering
if
our tolerance for violence is going down
and it's not necessarily i think
violence is getting is is up obviously
murders are way up but i'm wondering if
relative to political conflicts it's not
as much violence that will trigger a
civil war
civil conflict or something like that i
i i it's very interesting conversation i
think it's it's i'm calloused to this
stuff i've become calloused uh i see it
it doesn't hurt as bad i don't
immediately believe that guy's the
villain because i think i saw him punch
him like i don't know what's going on
but the downside is when you're
calloused you don't you can't really
feel i can't feel it it's not it's not
making me snap to attention maybe like
it should be um the downside is people
are going to go nuts faster the upside
is people can mobilize faster if there's
a real emergency like a some sort of
flood or whatever uh there are just to
tie this up 10 close 10 churches closer
uh to the courthouse than the
westminster presbyterian church which is
actually a little bit far like
interesting farther away
uh
sorry i mean it sounds like some local
that's a good point though but why a
federal courthouse maybe somebody who
works at the courthouse or just locally
to be disruptive i mean i think you're
still right that it could be tied to
ideology and they know they have access
to a federal courthouse in their town um
earlier i pitched like well we have to
see how far the church is because what
if the church is outside so when you
evacuate the building people come
outside and it's even more of a
dangerous situation um i think
when we just to tie it up back to what
you're saying with the new cycle i think
that these moments that feel like
breaking news you know for us
because we're watching the news it is
really interesting and for some people
they'll remember it
but they won't start to pay attention
until there's a pattern until there's
another federal courthouse in another
small town in another part of america
and then it will start to seem like oh
wait is something going on and at that
point we really have to ask ourselves
like
are we too late are we missing something
that's really significant that's going
on one of the mistakes people make is
when you hear stories about small rural
towns being you know targeted in this
way or whatever this was
they say well it's probably not
political because why would they come to
this small town and it's like okay you
know that's one way to think about it
but we have seen antifa go to small
towns we have seen riots in small towns
and the the idea behind that is
in order to inflict maximum terror if
you're engaged in political violence you
have to go to small towns
because people feel safe when they're
far away from the cities if the riots
and the attacks are happening in small
towns so that was the logic around why
far-left extremists were going to these
towns it's the logic behind why a
terrorist would attack a small town to
make sure that everyone feels terrified
of it but i don't know i mean either way
this looks like terror it was at a
courthouse i think that instantly
qualifies it a church
possibly but a church could be i suppose
both could be personal like a guy didn't
like an employee at either of these
places but who knows
i'll put it this way let's jump to this
next segment we'll just say this
world war three is racing civil war
because while we're hearing about
stories in like west virginia about
bombs we have this one a murder in
russia
i'm sure many of you have already heard
i believe it was saturday saturday
evening alexander dugan's daughter was
assassinated
in a car bombing
now initially they said it was meant for
him for those that aren't familiar with
dugan he is a highly influential
philosopher
nationalist in russia he's been referred
to as putin's brain or his spirit guide
or the spirit guide of ukrainian
invasion all of those things while
simultaneously some have also downplayed
his influence in the russian government
he's not explicitly a member of putin's
inner circle or anything like that
the atlantic writes about it why an
assassination in moscow matters to
ukraine and the west by tom nichols oh
we love this guy huh
he calls him a russian fascist
the daughter of a prominent russian
fascist was killed in a car bombing in
moscow most americans have no idea who
the dugan family is but this event could
have serious repercussions in russia and
ukraine
so
i don't want to jump the gun and say
that um
this is
world war three's franz ferdinand moment
franz ferdinand was a was a he was like
a royal royal family guy right the
archduke yeah and so when they killed
him like you've pissed off someone's
family member and then they all go to
war with each other this is like an
influential guy in russia's daughter
but then i want to point out too the
counterpoint there is while it well for
those reasons it may not be the catalyst
for an escalation
we're also in the influence era we're in
the you know the influence economy
so it is not necessarily politicians or
royal family that have the most
influence kim kardashian has more
influence than
every single politician
and so something someone who's that
influential ins in social has more
social credit than a politician
something affecting them will matter
more so so the way i described it
earlier today
if they had killed dugan
i think the impact would have been
substantially less
people in the russian government would
be like this is this is horrifying i
can't believe they did this
instead they killed dugan's daughter
whoever did it they uh it was reported
to by russian authorities cnn repeated
the reporting that they were observing
the vehicle and remotely detonated they
chose to detonate it it wasn't like she
turned the car and it went off someone
pressed a button
so presumably they knew it was her
this is substantially worse
because dugan is the man of influence
and now
all of that pain that he has will be
channeled into the influence he uses and
it will be heard over and over and over
again by all of his followers and his
followers that are in the government
so this has now
given him given him a reason to call for
more war more retribution more anger and
he will drive that you know to his
followers
honestly i don't know on his f on its
face it looks like ukrainians
killed dugan's daughter as retaliation
for the war in ukraine but i was reading
an article and they're like ah false
this is a this is a textbook russian
false flag could be a textbook russian
false flag operation and then i started
picturing like a conversation between
dugan and putin and dugan's like i would
give everything for this country
vladimir everything and vladimir's like
you would give everything and he's like
yeah i would and then putin's like all
right well then i'll kill his daughter
because he just he and i don't even feel
guilty about it because he already said
he'd sacrifice everything for it so
there reportedly he has said things
about sacrificing everything for the
cause and things like that but
to this extent i would just say
it is the simple solution that they blew
up his car and it was the wrong person
it's the simple solution that this guy
is a nationalist powerful influencer and
they wanted him gone i mean he's he's an
influential guy i mean people in the
west have interviewed him
they his ideas have spread all across
europe not saying they're completely
completely dominant across europe but a
lot of people have listened to this guy
and if you take a look at the right wing
the expansion of right-wing nationalism
across europe
well there are certainly many people who
don't like nationalism or the right
who would look at him as one of the key
components of pushing those ideas
so occam's razor occam's razor would
suggest in the absence of evidence the
solution that makes the least amount of
assumptions that's it
anti-you know
internationalist forces
probably ukrainian
targeted him in moscow
killed his daughter
i'll put this way too the reason it's
simple solution that it's ukraine i'm
not trying to blame them to call them
any names or anything but to point out
it's probably them
when you are the weaker fighting force
typically you see these groups engage in
more terroristic activities and targeted
assassinations and things like things
like this because
it's the best they could do in the
conflict for russia they're looking at a
conventional war you go in send in the
tanks send to the troops drop the bombs
for ukraine which is i think like the
poorest country in europe and it's like
the only country to get poor after the
fall of soviet union
they're they're they're thinking we have
to do whatever it takes and we don't
have much capabilities guerrilla warfare
it is him in moscow that seems to make
more sense it's the simplest solution
for sure but in war propaganda they will
use the simplest solution against you to
make you think that that's what it is i
think if they had assassinated dugan
outright they would have risked a more
serious retribution from putin i
disagree well my thought in here is that
his daughter dugan's daughter was
involved in his influence and she she
was also seen like not on the
international level that she was but
within the country she is an advocate
for his policies and beliefs so in some
way
she they are uh maybe
effectively hurting the morale of the
russian people by targeting by choosing
to
detonate the car when she was in it as
opposed to him while still being able to
like say it wasn't quite as aggressive
as outright right detonating you know
this person who has tremendous influence
in a relationship with the nation's
president the one thing that i would say
that is a counterpoint that suggests it
may actually be a false flag or you know
russians doing this because we actually
have a story here let me pull this up
from daily mail car bomb attack on
putin's rasputin who vladimir deemed
uncontrollable has all the hallmarks of
a russian gru execution because military
spy group often include a target's
family i don't see why they would go
after dugan they're saying because the
kremlin deemed him unruly
the one thing i would say that makes me
think it could be a false flag although
i don't think it is
getting his daughter
was the worst possible thing you can do
in terms of escalation
so to to disagree with you a bit
dugan's voice would be lost if he died
if your goal was to amplify his message
of nationalism
and get a martyr
you'd go after his daughter
because now you've got a martyr someone
who holds the same ideas as him who who
speaks the same ideas who is considered
by the west a propagandist who is
considered by you know russia as a
journalist
you get your martyr
you keep dugan's voice you amplify
dugan's voice with a major story about
how he's now a victim targeted by the
the the the um excesses of the west
now you've exemplified his message
amplified his message and created a
martyr all at the same time it's the
worst possible thing for escalation well
unless you're putin and you want to get
the russian people excited about
attacking ukraine because they think
that exactly what i'm saying
i don't think it's true look i'm seeing
a lot of these democrats they're like he
killed his own daughter and i'm like
that's nuts that's crisis actor level
conspiracy nonsense sorry dude unless
you can come out and show me a video of
him planting the bomb or whatever i'm
not going to believe he killed his own
daughter
i'm picturing putin going to uh
alexander and being like i'm so sorry
about your daughter and then making full
eye contact and alexander knowing that
putin killed her and just looking at him
like thank you sir and they both know
it's just true that's just
hollywood to me exactly i don't think
that that's realistic i think in some
ways we believe that
vladimir put putin and for good reason
is like uh an intense
leader who has committed crimes that
like the west finds horrifying
but i don't think that
there would be any benefit especially if
we already think this guy is unruly then
like being like and then i killed your
daughter like they could deemed him
unruly how do we know he's not going to
flip and be like i hate putin now you
know what i mean like it it doesn't do
anything for putin to try and antagonize
or play with a variable that isn't
dependable if they really do believe
he's unruly i think that
i mean the most
to me the most straightforward answer is
like this was an attempted assassination
i haven't read enough to know where
dugan was in relation to the car was
even there like
to me it makes more sense that they are
trying to
both be aggressive and also passive
aggressive at the same time and they see
as taking out his daughter as uh an
aggressive move without
while still being able to say well we're
not the aggressors in this war so so to
your point ian you're saying you know
it's like you're imagining putin looking
in the eyes and it's very
hollywood-esque my counterpoint to that
would be
the reality is likely some fat
middle-aged ukrainian dude with a couple
bombs like waddling over the car and
then like slapping it with duct tape and
then walking away and then waiting for
it again and then pressing a button and
going oh i'm like running away like
scraggly dudes no like i'm not imagining
you know spetsnaz like commandos like
going in and like the earpieces and
they're like do it and then
it's probably it's it's pr it's rogish
it's gorilla stuff it's probably like
hobo looking dudes you know who are
angry who are zealous and probably
ukrainian and there are a fair number of
ukrainians who have gone to russia since
the start of the war um so there is a
ukrainian population within the country
i mean i assume some are there because
they want to be and some are there maybe
because they had to go uh but it it
russia is not insulated from having uh
ukrainian actors be within its
boundaries
i i don't i will not decide i don't even
like the word probable now because
war fog is so
the it's ripe for
for disillusionment and you want to
trick people and you want to create that
so
the most obvious answer a lot of times
when war is not the right answer the the
open field that looks like the best path
is probably the kill zone so you don't
want to go through it kind of thing and
i'm going to wait and see if they use
this as is just as a reason to go harder
in ukraine than that's like what russia
is saying ukraine did it of course
someone just super chatted in the pale
moonlight tim you guys know what that's
a reference to
no no star trek fans for shame uh deep
space nine um in the pale moonlight
brilliant television spoiler alert
spoiler alert it's like a 30 year old
show but i'm gonna spoil it for you
uh benjamin cisco is the is the
commander of an outpost for the
federation the star trek
a war breaks out
the the federation which is the main
characters
are being defeated by they're slowly
being pushed back and they're losing the
war to the dominion
there's another race called the romulans
and they're typically there's an
armistice between the federation and the
romulans they hate each other
they they go to them and say you have to
join the war on our side otherwise after
we're defeated the dominion will come
and crush you and they're like
no they won't and we don't care we can
handle ourselves
so the commander stages a false flag
where he blows up a senator in a
spaceship and plants evidence to make it
seem i could be getting this wrong but
something like this makes it seem like
the dominion did it forcing the romulans
to join the war on the side of the
federation now that we've gotten the
fictional fund writing out of the way
there's a very possibility that the goal
here was a false flag and it was to
rally the the russian people saying look
they killed this young woman she was 29
years old they're targeting our children
this is horrible we need your support in
this war
and depending on what you read
western propaganda says
ukraine's winning
eastern propaganda says ukraine's losing
who knows man of war it's an emotional
assassination that was not a tactical
assassination that didn't take out a
leader or military command or anything
and car bombs are crude
yeah super super crude and a lot of
collateral damage it was not a surgical
maneuver
well i'm i'm shocked that they would
claim that anyone has done it that they
would deign to act like they know who
did it and if they do know who did it
how do they know who did it
i want to know it doesn't matter and
that's ultimate it comes down to it
doesn't matter who did you know why
because in the east they're going to say
in russia and in china they're going to
say it was
the uh ukrainians it was nato
in the west they're posting all over
twitter that it was a false flag that
dugan killed his own daughter because
they have to because both sides have to
there's a narrative they have to keep up
yep
and in the end we'll just be left
wondering what actually happened the
good news is whoever wins will tell us
for sure honestly well yeah they'll give
us the whole story the history for us
the history books and then they'll let
us read them with all the details don't
even worry about it do you think that
the russians are going to just end up
taking the eastern part of ukraine get
access to the red sea and then it'll be
over
i mean i think i agree that the part
that is interesting wouldn't it be nice
to actually
know
what happened yes
and not of course it doesn't even end
with this right there's so many examples
in history where it's still unclear what
exactly happened
um who gained who lost who was behind
sort of who was
who was um
who was pulling the strings to to to you
know create a series of events it
certainly it does have the feel of that
that um you know not an accident i mean
it could have been and i agree that
that's sort of the simplest
answer you know occam's razor but um boy
it seems awfully dastardly to
to just have a simple explanation let's
jump to uh another hard segue and jump
back to the medical stuff it was it was
a bit tough i'll just you know as an
aside because we've got um you know
obviously big stories without cheese
resignation but also the war and they're
like very distinct and so like trying to
segue between them is not really
possible
but we'll jump to this one from the
post-millennial
seattle children's hospital offers
medicalized gender transition to
nine-year-olds quote we accept new
patients ages 9 to 16 the site reads
patients ages 17 and older and patients
who have not yet started puberty will be
directed to community resources
this is part of a long-standing story a
long chain of stories boston's
children's boston children's hospital
big controversy surrounding that the
media claiming there's threats going
their way you've got to think now a
hospital in chicago performing these uh
these transitions for minors and now we
have the latest story from
post-millennial that seattle is doing
the same thing
i know that um
there was recently a board review in
florida the medical board did a review
of uh
uh sex change operations for children
and and medical and other transitions
uh i surprised you to throw it to you uh
joe you probably know better what's
going on with florida as
it pertains to child gender transition
well you know florida is taking an
unequivocal stand that is just there
with the data
it's not very dissimilar it's actually
worse in terms of evidence you know we
had the mass discussion previously at
least a study showed you know a
reduction from 12 percent to 11 which is
a 10 reduction i mean if if you really
think that that's enough to force people
to do things you know we can have a
conversation about that but in this case
the data
you know the data are even they're just
they're incredibly weak i mean there's
basically in it and it speaks to
dishonesty so the cdc quotes that
extremely
unimpressive mask study and says oh this
shows that you can actually reduce
community transmission
then and so you know which like to to
someone who looked at it
they would say that doesn't make sense
in this case it's the same thing the
data you know people advocates say that
oh it's this is the standard of care and
it work it helps people you know it
makes them less likely to compete commit
suicide and things like that but the
data actually don't show that at all
so for for uh
we did we did a members-only segment
where we read de-transitioner statements
yeah and there are a lot of teenage
women because i think it's like
overwhelmingly teenage girls who are
getting these surgeries uh double
mastectomies and things like that at
least there was there was actually one
study from the nih we pulled up showing
that 90
of what they reviewed were double
mastectomies on
on females
and the average age i think was like 15
or something like that
so
we read these stories where they're
they're suicidal it's it's horrifying
no no no i mean like the idea here is
i think there's something happening i do
i think i think gender dysphoria is real
i think there are kids who are
transgender and i think we have to pay
attention to
there was one
article i read last week from psychology
today
a phd researcher saying we know that
phthalates and pcbs
are our hormone disruptors
he he cited a study the showing that
certain birth control had a
masculinizing effect on female fetuses
on their brains and it resulted in women
who preferred the company of women and
did not prefer childbearing and things
like that
and so that point was
there's an environmental factor coming
from the chemicals and the
pharmaceuticals we use that is likely
contributing to this
i think that's true i mean i think even
alex jones has pointed that out he's
mocked for when he mentioned talked
about atrazine
and so i think the result there is okay
we need to figure that out stop that but
this does mean they're going to be trans
kids and how do we effectively solve for
this problem how do we make sure these
kids are going to be happy healthy not
suicidal and the issue seems to be
the the accepted medical treatment
across the country united states is at
odds with what europe is now doing with
the scandinavian countries who have
rejected all of this stuff and the end
result for a lot of these people i'm not
saying all of them
we're seeing them post online saying
after undergoing these surgeries and
these medical treatments they are worse
than they were before
yeah that's that's a scary outcome and
we want to prevent that we want to make
sure that kids who are suffering from
dysphoria or whatever the issue may be
hormone disruptors be it the case how do
we help them when you've got
these extreme policies that are all
going in one way and ignoring the
science that we can see in other places
no it's a great summary and you're
absolutely right they're definitely boys
who think feel like they're girls girls
who feel like they're boys that's that's
like that's nothing there's nothing new
there
but that's a different and i agree with
you right understanding trying to do
what we can to understand why that is
that's an important goal
but that is a
different issue than what to do about in
terms of medical or surgical therapies
and standards of professional care and
that's the issue that florida is focused
on and standards of professional care
you know it's just i've actually i mean
i you know covet before this like i was
a mainstream
doctor researcher
very mainstream right i you know like
and i i did you know fortunately i did
well but i was there was nothing
controversial about me
and since covet it's just opened my eyes
to
examples of medical organizations just
completely misleading people and
essentially in some cases lying in this
particular case
at the end of the day
you have
experimental therapies right that are
not vitamin d like these are serious and
real quick not fda approved treatments
for these kids i'm not sure that i mean
i don't know that the fda authorizes
medical therapies they certainly are
authorized drugs and devices but i i
don't think that they authorize my
understanding is correct if i'm wrong i
think you know this lupron is not fda
approved it's it's off-label use yes
blocker so that's what i have heard i
don't know if i'm correct there it isn't
i believe that's correct yeah
my point is some cancer this is this is
really fun to point out
uh lupron is can you someone want to
check that real quick i want to make
sure we get this right because my
understanding is it is an off-label use
as a puberty blocker in kids
yeah off-label is not actually that's
not a big deal doctors can
prescribe things off label and they do
it all the time except there are some
things you can't what does off-label
mean
well off actually well off label means
that you know the fda when they approve
a drug they approve it for specific
indications if a drug company wants to
expand the indications you know they
have to provide data let's give it to
the fda and the fda has to approve it
for that new indication so that's how
that without runs off label first it's
off label so my point here is and
without mentioning any other treatments
other than this because we don't you
know my point is there are
mainstream narratives
that if you mention off-label use on
some drugs you're a dangerous conspiracy
theorist meanwhile the narrative from
the establishment is to actively promote
this particular off-label use which we
are seeing notifications of in there and
they're kind of devastating for a lot of
these kids so ultimately i think
you mentioned it the hypocrisy the lies
and all that it's all here my question
is
what is florida doing differently and so
i guess i wanted to get this very very
much at the beginning i watched the live
stream where the medical board was
discussing this what ended up happening
with that
well the medical board
basically you know their their task that
day was to decide whether they were
going to take on the issue because right
now essentially it's an unregulated
space right you've got different centers
you know who are there you go seattle
children's hospital nine years old right
some hospitals they may not see patients
until they're 14 or 15. some refuse to
do surgery or say they're not going to
do surgery unless they're at least 18.
so different you know different
practices at different places and the
board of medicine in florida said that
they were going to look at that and the
goal really from in my in my opinion
should be that they that they stop these
therapies
in children who are under 18 unless
there's evidence and i'll just say
really quickly right people make things
so complicated and confusing
at the end of the day right you've got
high risk procedures right puberty
blockers when the brain is developing at
a young age
sex change operations mastectomies the
risk of infertility sterility
high risk not vitamin d not other
off-label drugs
and you've got
uncertain benefit like no one knows
people will tell you with a straight
face that they know it's going to help
they don't know that not just that we
have 37 000 almost 40 000 people on a
forum d trans where there are prominent
posts
every day yeah of people saying they are
suicidal now i don't want these people
to feel that way i want them to be happy
and healthy and we have to figure out
how to help them and this certainly is
not resulting in that
well there was maybe some people a woman
who spoke at the florida board of
medicine during the public comment
section her name was i think sophia
galvin and she specifically talked about
her experience like as a minor
uh
being incur not i don't encourage what
she was when she decided that she wanted
transition her school was supportive she
was the president of their lgbt
community she was encouraged to undergo
a mastectomy she went on years of
testosterone and it was not happier
afterwards and through spiritual and
personal growth ultimately decided to
de-transition and is now a really strong
advocate against this i thought her
testimony there was really powerful
i i think you're totally right i mean it
was interesting to me that when it was i
think the american academy of pediatrics
uh decided to sort of
block the issue they had doctors saying
that they wanted to talk about it and
they suppressed the motion uh all of the
doctors there were pointing to studies
from europe that were like look i i
think it's finland just went back to
saying the first treatment for minors
who are experiencing gender dysphoria is
to go through psychotherapy it's not to
me intervene medically i was a
tremendous amount of gaslighting europe
sweden this year released they've been
doing this for years longer than we have
in the united states these gender
transition therapies they released a
their equivalent of sort of the nih
released a new guidance this year and
they said they're not going to do it
anymore for for children because they
just didn't know whether they were doing
more harm than good and they literally
said that but you have doctors in
in some in florida who say that no we
know better and you know we're helping
every patient that we see who undergoes
this
i think um
have you have you read about uh
endocrine disruptors and hormone
disruptors sure assuming you have yeah
there was one uh article that i read
that kind of went viral mentioning uh i
mentioned it earlier there was a birth
control women would take it and in the
rare chance taking it they still got
pregnant it was having a masculinizing
effect on on their fetuses and if it was
a female you know it was it was causing
issues
i think
when you look at the uh the great words
of uh alex jones they're turning the
frickin frogs gay
but to get more specific and not play
the silly game he was talking about i
think it's a pesticide called atrazine
we've talked about this before there was
a uh there was a study this is like 10
years ago i think showing that it was
interfering with the endocrine systems
of frogs turning ovaries into testes
testing into ovaries causing a
population collapse and alex pointed
that out
i see stories like that and i'm like
yeah we've long known that there are
like hormones in our drinking water in
cities and plastics are leaching into
our water or you know some people have
argued that soy is doing these things
although i'm not sure that's correct but
okay there's there's probably serious
hormones and hormone disruptors being
consumed and affecting kids who are
developing
so when bill maher says
they're in california they're not in
ohio either we're shaming in them or
creating them i'm like
the the the argument from from bill
misses a big picture there i mean it's a
fair point he's like how come in ohio
there's not a lot of trans kids in
california there is
it sounds like he's making the point
that it's trendy in california and it
probably is
but
my point here is
it could be that california uses
specific chemicals in agriculture that
ohio doesn't and it is causing these
children to become
you know have hormonal imbalance or
disruption in utero which results in
trans kids
that's something we absolutely need to
talk about considering the science is
there to show that's a possibility
so that being said
i think what we're seeing is a mix
i think we're probably seeing a natural
there's a natural phenomenon of people
who are transgender i think that
probably naturally exists in humans to
some degree i think we're seeing a large
uptick in trans kids probably because of
the pesticides the chemicals the
pharmaceuticals as these other studies
have pointed out and i also think we're
seeing social trends which affect some
kids so the problem is if you approach
this with a one size fits all start with
the surgery then you're going to wrap up
kids who do not need this and create
suicidal teenagers
we probably need to approach this and
figure out what is the underlying cause
of the gender dysphoria in this child is
it a social issue or is it a naturally
you know a developmental issue
i hear you and i i think that
i it's definitely an interesting
scientific question but i think it's
it's probably not the priority i hear
your your example the you know the
problem is right and
you look at and i totally agree with you
frankly you know i i mean we try and eat
organic as much as possible but it's
it's really sad how much junk like
poison really in terms of some of the
pesticides and some of them are hormone
disrupting and some of them increase the
risk of cancer that get into food and
then you've got you know their financial
interests to try and maintain
the use of these chemicals but you look
at europe and my understanding is that
they don't use they don't nearly use
nearly the type of
the intensity of pesticides that we use
and they have also seen in some areas
the same explosive growth in terms
particularly in girls who feel like they
should be boys so i you know i i i
hear you and i think that area is
important but i don't think that's what
you know that's what that's not what the
the the focus ought to be you think it's
social
social impact i think it's likely that
there's a substantial social component
and it's you know the curves in terms of
the growth it's just not really
consistent with like for example
one of the things that um that's been
noticed is that the age of puberty was
changing right it was getting lower for
different age groups and that was a sort
of a gradual process and that's kind of
how biological processes tend to be
right they're sort of gradual this has
not been gradual this has been explosive
yeah and that or argues less for a
biological mechanism and and at least
you know but it's it could be that
there's a critical mass of phthalates
phthalates or like pesticides or that
we've somehow reached critical mass
we're like you can eat salt but if you
get too much salt it will kill you like
you can't do over salt will destroy your
body so like if the now the levels of
phthalates are we just hit the ceiling
of what we can handle maybe
i'm not i'm not making those
i'm not trying to prescribe a treatment
based on the idea what i'm simply trying
to say is
that
for one i oppose sex changes for kids i
i think you've you've got to be 18
before you start doing this stuff there
is a question about you know the limits
on
when government can intervene to stop
parents from engaging in certain medical
treatments but at certain point you know
i'm just like values
over
where you know
my values are we don't give kids sex
change surgeries it's just that's where
it is for me for whatever reason
but my point is
there's likely a natural of of causing
gender dysphoria
now i'm not saying we should be giving
consecration surgeries because of it we
clearly look at the scandinavian
countries they're not doing that anymore
but i think the the the issue of the
social factor is also obviously playing
a role whether it's you know you're
saying it's explosive so that's likely
the case either way that's evidence
enough that we should not be doing this
to kids
to ian's point
i think there it's entirely possible
there's a combination of
we were seeing hormone disrupters in in
our food supply plastics or whatever
increasing but also serious social
discouragement from anyone mentioning it
so it could be
you know the left says there's always
been trans people and the reason there's
a massive explosion of them is because
now it's finally okay for them to speak
up it's like it could actually be both
it could be that in the past 10 years
past 20 years we've massively increased
the amount of pcbs state lights what is
it poly chloride something i don't know
we've dramatically increased certain
hormones pharmaceuticals plastics and
other things into our food supply that
is their hormone disruptors
but the people who grew up experiencing
that didn't say anything because it was
not socially acceptable now that it is
all of a sudden now there's a perception
that among the left it's only happening
because it's acceptable these are pcbs
are polychlorinated biphenols there you
go the biphenyls i mean for me some of
this just
makes me have more questions about like
reproduction and human fertility because
if we do believe there's a genetic link
or an environmental disruption that
occurs
where does it come from is it because
you have uh
moms like a generation of moms who've
been on birth control for longer and
that disrupts their hormones which
disrupts how their uh fetus i mean i
don't know anything about medical
science so this is all speculation on my
part i defer to the doctor but i wonder
if
ultimately
we just don't know
what causes any of these issues because
we are not studying it holistically like
we are looking at it as social
intervention when they reach school but
what if this is something that has to do
with mom's nutrition yeah and you know
what i'm gonna i'm gonna back pedal a
little bit so i i
what you said earlier resonates with me
in terms of
you know in terms of attention on
studying it and i'll tell you that just
to your point
one of the problems right with these hot
button issues is that it becomes taboo
to even ask the questions right and
that's a problem
yep i like looking at what i do know is
that pharmaceutical companies are
administering for-profit surgeries and
chemicals in reaction to whatever is
happening that's very apparent yeah the
for-profit medical industry there's no
incentive to not encourage if you have
kids that you're treating for more and
more things plus when you go on hormones
there are side effects you take more
medication i mean like this becomes a
mass industry in and of itself why would
you discourage it if you are a
pharmaceutical person not to be too
conspiratorial oh there's no conspiracy
about pharmaceutical companies pursuing
profit over everything else it is well
documented we we've heard it from a
doctor well we uh we pointed out there's
a an article about goldman sachs they
said they were advising pharmaceutical
companies i think i could be wrong
because we don't have the article pulled
up but they were saying
curing diseases is not a long-term
you know financial gain for us yeah yeah
yeah that like
you're better off just treating the
symptoms and letting people stay sick
which is just so horrifying yeah well i
it's like i don't want to call them
medical companies anymore i want to call
because the real medicine in my opinion
is food like if you're eating the right
diet you know that's what hippocrates
said the first doctor let food be thy
medicine let me let me ask you this
uh why do you think it is
that
testosterone levels are are are dropping
so
significantly in the male population
yeah it's then it's true right first of
all that's like that's been documented
um
this might be a good time to mention by
the way that there was a study that came
out in a good journal about
reproductive health and hormones that
showed that followed some men after they
underwent coven 19 vaccination with one
of the mrna vaccines
and that was followed by a decrease in
in sperm count
and in sperm motility and
it didn't so that was really nice
wording if you looked at the table and
this is this is uh again this is like my
space right in the space of a lot of my
colleagues that i work with
so if you pull up that study it was
published a few months ago and you look
at the table
doesn't look
fully temporary so the the levels that i
can't remember whether it was 12 weeks
afterward the measures are still lower
than baseline and at least one of the
cells in the in the uh one of the areas
in the table was substantially lower
than baseline so anyway i digress i will
i will just i'll state just because we
we segment the
we create segments so previous
statements won't be heard in this one uh
we've got to be careful about single
studies
when one study comes out and shows
something you need way more than that
before you can draw heavy conclusions as
to what they mean correct
well
you do need to be careful
in this particular study it was done
it seemed like it was done well there
was another study that was done earlier
in the pan am pandemic that didn't find
a difference that there they concluded
that there wasn't a difference in sperm
function or sperm count
so that that's true
ultimately the truth is one you know one
of those studies is is accurate
i think from what i've seen it was it's
there probably is a decrement in the in
the in the activity in the in the counts
of the sperms coming back to your point
and in terms of um in terms of
these testosterone so that fits the
pattern of something that isn't
environmental some environmental
exposure and we have a lot of them
so you know why is it i don't know but
it does fit the pattern of you know a
sort of non-natural phenomenon but you
know could it be
social
so uh men aren't chopping lumber anymore
i mean physical exercise increases
testosterone right
it i do believe it does but more in
older men really i'm not sure about i'm
not sure if it increases testosterone if
it's related to testosterone levels in
younger men i i'm not sure what about
hunching over staring at a computer
screen drinking pepsi for 12 hours you
can joke around but guys asking for no
help
it's actually i mean that's a legitimate
question right i mean you know to give
one example i don't know if this is
correct but
if this is true but if some some um you
know i've read for example that the
increase in people with nearsightedness
is related to you know the fact that we
are looking at screens more and kind of
doing close stuff instead of looking
things farther away or hunting or
whatever
so no i i don't i mean it's funny but
something real is happening those
testosterone levels are substantially
lower than they were in the past have
you have you seen the infamous try guys
video
which infamous one i don't know which
where they get their testosterone yeah
they get their testosterone levels
checked and they have the test out
they're like how old are they in their
20s i think they're all late 20s maybe
early 30s at the time
and their testosterone levels were equal
to 80 year old men
yeah i don't
i'm i yeah
okay you know from the top looking down
if someone's in the computer all day
that's kind of like them telling biology
you're not going to need my sperm i am a
machine i'm an electronic organism i'm
going to implant my brain in a machine
when i'm 30 doesn't matter you don't
need me anyway my so the body's just
like i mean obviously this guy's not
interacting with women he doesn't need
to be producing testosterone he's
getting are you telling us something hey
i love my girlfriend alright
she plays video games too
uh but yeah i am telling you something
when i started doing youtube and making
videos i threw world of warcraft away i
broke the cd and tossed it in the gutter
because i had a massive video game
addiction and for two years i didn't
touch them and i created the most
amazing career uh and created some of
the best friendships of my life to this
day uh video games on video games off
video it was all off youtube became my
video game uh interacting with people
became my video game so
there's no understanding of why
testosterone levels are dropping really
i wish i had studied it better prepared
for your quiz today yeah no i i just
it's not an area i've studied i wish i
had and it isn't important what do you
think like dudes are going to become
shorter weaker less muscle mass less
bone density i think it's probably not a
good thing that testosterone levels are
you know are falling i see i see this i
see this meme all the time that says the
y chromosome is disappearing have you
heard that i haven't heard that all
right
so i think it miss uh it's it's feminist
misunderstanding what the science
actually is obviously but it's that
males so i was reading about it
males evolve faster than females in
humans at least
and or or should i i should say this is
a related to the greater male
variability hypothesis are you familiar
with that one i'm no i'm not i'm not at
all this this one is uh greater male
male variability uh hypothesis states
that among men there will be a greater
variation in physical traits
uh as opposed to women and that's
because
you know men this the best the strongest
most successful will reproduce with the
women right
and so if you have a wide if you have
zero iq to uh to a thousand iq that wide
range allows the best of the best to
have stronger and better children and to
try and fight you know fight for the
women and then women can choose
whichever man is is better or the you
know depending on what year it is if
it's the caveman era it's not not so
pretty for the women
but so
uh in that
the idea basically is if i forgot where
i was what i was starting on now that
we're talking about greater than the y
chromosomes disappearing right the idea
is that among the greater variability of
males the y chromosome changes
substantially
so you know to create a higher chance of
mutations and alterations in the human
body and then the failure mutations
cease to exist die off don't have kids
the successful mutations end up having
kids feminists have taken this to say oh
because the y chromosome is smaller now
than it was before or whatever that
means men will eventually disappear
instead of well the reality is it could
get bigger and larger and just come back
in force who knows i'll miss you guys
when you all disappear i have really
enjoyed it
we're alive now be on mars so we're not
just gonna die and you're not gonna be
immortal or maybe i don't know maybe
that sounds like awful there are no like
it's just a bunch of women we're in the
oceans movie all over again i live in
new york and it's basically that already
isn't it pass not forget
you know i'll tell you that i i haven't
heard of
i'm not familiar with that sort of
theory
i'll tell you what kind of along the
same lines is concerning
are individuals who believe that
the differences between boys and girls
don't have a natural
root
that
i've read these people's writings and
and they're just completely they're
disconnected from reality because boys
and girls are different
oh don't get me started man you know i
read this study once that said
at birth like within 24 hours female
infants and male infants react to things
differently like female infants are uh
much more interested in faces and male
infants are much more likely to be
looking at like what's beeping
from the beginning show differences
like mechanical options right right i
just watched a video on instagram i
think about a seven-year-old doing a 900
on a skateboard maybe it was nine i
don't know either way he was in the
single digits of age
a nine-year-old boy a seven-year-old boy
just this tiny little kid tiny the board
was as tall as he was
and it was one of the
just most amazing so for those
unfamiliar with skateboarding 900 it's
like a legit seriously difficult
maneuver
uh it was first done in 1999 by tony
hawk it was considered a huge moment in
the history of skateboarding and then
the fir the second one was landed you
know like 10 years later i think it was
something like that maybe it was like
eight years later or something but then
the first 1080 which is three complete
rotations was done by a 12 year old boy
12 year old boy so tony hawk was like 30
when he landed the first 900 which is
two and a half spins
followed by a 12 year old boy did the
first full three rotations adding an
extra half spin to it
now you've got little kids in the single
digits landing this once
insane move
no girls
no girls they're proves it
but but i mean it's it's it's anecdotal
but maybe it's a little bit more than
that if you're doing an observational
study and you take a look at all of the
10 year old boys and girls who have been
skating the same amount of time and you
wonder why it is that even before
puberty
boys are landing historical feats and
skateboarding and the girls don't come
close and when i say don't come close i
mean with with all due respect
when when you know when you watch tennis
i couldn't tell you the difference if i
see two guys playing tennis
i see him hitting the ball i see two and
play tennis i see him hitting the ball
don't know because i can't see it
you show anyone skateboarding and you
show them a 12 year old boy jumping a 70
foot gap then going up a 25 foot tall
wall a half pipe quarter pipe and
landing a 1080 45 feet up in the air and
you're going wow
and then you watch the girls skate it
and they don't do it at all because it's
too advanced and they're the same age
with the same same year's skateboarding
there's there's clearly something there
so i researched it the first thing
that's really obvious is fast switch
muscles from prenatal uh as a result of
prenatal testosterone which is is my
understanding a huge factor in muscle
development so even before puberty
this this idea that if you give these
these sex changes to these children or
hormonal therapies before they hit
puberty they can become the other
you know at least to a to a greater
degree passing or whatever they want to
call it
that's that's all in the eye the
beholder i suppose the issue is
even before puberty from birth there are
distinct physical differences that are
very obvious and discernible between
males and females
yeah i think that's true i mean you
would know better than that i
always think about um
this
tweet that i saw and it was a dad being
like there was a there was a time and it
probably still true but when it was
really big to be like you gotta you
gotta give your kids not like a mixed
array of gender toys so if you have a
daughter buy her barbies but also buy
her tonka trunks if you have a son get
him a play kitchen as well as like tools
or whatever it is to encourage you know
not being trapped in gender stereotypes
and this dad was like oh i did it and he
takes a picture and it's his daughter
who has tucked her tonka trucks into bed
into like a barbie bed because for
whatever reason like the trucks are her
babies and she's gonna take care of them
and that is really inherent he's this
dad is actively trying to not reinforce
gender stereotypes and she's doing it
anyways i think physiologically and in
the brain there are clear differences
from an early age and it is confusing
for children to be told well you
shouldn't behave that way because it's
sort of bad in a way that is complicated
to explain to you um i don't know why
this also occurred to me one of the
things i think about the try guy video
when they test their testosterone
i don't know a ton about them but i know
that the only the guy who's scored the
highest on the test not that it's like a
winning but sort of winning uh is the
only one who's married and he might
still be i'm not sure but like at the
time he was the only married guy so so
the question
marriage correlation was was getting
married
what caused his testosterone to go up or
is it because he had high testosterone
he got or are our marriage rates falling
because our testosterone rates are
falling i think that's probably very
likely and i i attribute personally a
lot to diet when i eat crappy i do not
feel sexy at all and normally i feel
sexy let me just get that on the table i
don't know though you look at people
like
tiger woods wasn't he he was like called
promiscuous sort of south park did a
whole thing on it that was really funny
i don't know if you guys ever saw that
south park episode where they're like we
don't understand why it is that rich
successful men are sleeping with so many
women like what's what's going what's up
with that they could they were confused
by it
so i actually wonder if
i don't know if the marriage thing
correlates to a certain degree right low
t guys are probably not successful in
their relationships but i would i would
argue that the high tea guys
the you know like what we're seeing with
the um
it was the okay cupid data that women
overwhelmingly choose the top 20 of men
so like the higher tea guys are getting
all the women yeah you know well and
like not getting married either high
testosterone correlates to the way you
present right like i don't know if this
is true but someone told me once that uh
men going bald is actually a sign of
high testosterone in men and so like
there are things that socially we
wouldn't necessarily think of that we
are subtly picking up on the way people
present or you know you probably can do
this but i i don't like quoting medical
advice in front of the doctor the the
speaking from experience the the
baldness thing is sensitivity to i think
dht
what's dht you know that better than me
was it diet remember i mean hydrogen
testosterone is that it is um because
you know look i got to be honest
me and brian stouter are very different
people neither of us have hair so
you know it's like the warrior in you
like your hair's already gone so no one
can grab it if you find yourself in
combat maybe
well you know um
i don't know i i wear my hair short but
what i will contribute to this
conversation is that we've got three
boys and we do exactly that because you
know whatever like we just let them
play with what they want right so what
these some of these people believe is
that well it's all a construct boys only
like you know they like the toy cars
because that's all you give them and
girls like the dolls because that's all
you give them and obviously they're
exceptions to everything but that's
that's that is literally factually
incorrect you know yes i think it's i
think the right thing to do is to let
your kids play what they want because
guess what
that's who they are and you you can
fight it as long as you want but that
will never change and so you ought not
fight it and you should go with what
whoever what they are you know there's
something interesting to be said about
um
not knowing things exist they can't ask
for it right right right no yes exactly
so
what we do is we let them play with what
they want it just so it turns out that
you know one of our boys likes this type
of toy the other way and they all you
know they all like kind of boys stuff
but um you know so anyway i agree with
letting them play with whatever they
want yeah i think it's funny that
they're like you know girls play with
dolls and boys play with action figures
like bro they're dolls
joints
i had barbies growing up for a little
while and all of my brother's g.i joes
would occasionally come by and either
murder my garbage or marry them it was
really hard to tell what would happen i
want to encourage people not to well one
of the things i'm concerned with is that
people will overcompensate with this
conversation of testosterone and they go
for the high tea because i think a
balanced tea you see i think john mcafee
i don't want to put the guy on blast
john if you're still out there i love
you man what do you mean if he's still
out there he's still alive
he uploaded himself i think he was high
tea like was was taking testosterone
supplements you can see his face is
really red skin is very leathery like
too much yeah no it can increase the
risk of um of blood clots for example i
mean i i don't recommend that what i do
recommend is that people eat as clean as
possible in terms of avoiding the you
know pesticides eating as organic as
possible
which like used to be how all food was
but now you actually have to go seek it
out and exercising right you know some
some resistance training too
i mean you know that's probably as good
as you can do overall these days
all right we're gonna go to super chats
in like one second
because uh youtube keeps crashing on us
so we found a new way to read super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends and head over to timcast.com
become a member we're going to have a a
very fun and exciting members only show
coming up at 11 p.m talking about covid
florida their response and a lot of that
stuff so check that out over at
timcast.com but let's um
let's read some of these super chats let
me try and find the first one
raymond g stanley jr what's up man he
says hey guys just wanted to thank you
again for having mike glover on irl and
uncensored are worth a second uh irl and
uncensored are worth a second watch his
knowledge is valuable to us all he was
great he was so great he was really fun
to have on
all right let's see
uh joe burns says what is it oh here
slipping that over to you what is this
that's why
one of the reasons i'm here we're
getting some book recommendations
why i wrote a book that's coming out
tomorrow and that's one of the reasons
i've booked with tim oh transcend fear
by uh joseph lattipo
well we'll we'll we'll get you uh we'll
get you to shout out in a second let's
read some super chats we saw about half
an hour so we're good
joe burns says ian have you ever looked
into nano diamond battery technology
they're self-charging nuclear batteries
which are supposed to last for thousands
of years interesting
anyway moving on
uh let's see
let's grab another one
neil sawyer says it deeply saddens me to
see him resign just to make sure you let
the door hit you in the tuckers on the
way out you dang ghoul what a terrible
man
i just want to know if harvard and yale
are like please come to our medical
schools and if that's going to be the
sign that they are no longer credible
institutions
not that they are i just adjusting
already recommending booster shots and
healthy young people so how credible was
that
john diaz says tim lately you've been
saying you guys are winning you can beat
the establishment in your vids and i
wanted to thank you because you're right
i had lost hope but you helped me see it
yeah um in one week i mean this is like
the greatest white pill moment
liz cheney loses her election
then we get uh
brian stelter is fired from cnn they
canceled the show and you know fired
whatever colloquial term or i mean uh
opinion let's call it that he severed
ties with him several ties and then
fouchy and then as an honorable you know
little little bump sam harris outs
himself as a dangerous authoritarian
lunatic and then discredits himself so
uh the same air is one thing i think
doesn't really fit but you get you know
they say it comes in threes
major major victory i mean carrie lake
wins
uh hageman wins
i mean you got to be looking at this and
thinking
you're taking the field you know so come
november go and vote i liked your idea
of like tell all your friends you're
going to get pizza up but insist that
you drive and drive them to the polls
really quick stop at the local polling
place
or you know you can be like hey
everybody we're going to go uh we're
gonna go grab pizza but make sure you
bring your mail and ballot with you yeah
i do get worried do it people will do it
i do get worried about like complacency
i think that it's great to celebrate
victories and
let's just not back down yet you know
brandon hamson says hannah claire is
worried about tim like squidward was
worried about mr krebs oh no who's going
to sign my paychecks
no i worry about tim generally but you
guys have to admit it would be sad if
the best news site of all time
teamcast.com could not function because
tim had brain damage
waxia game central says you really need
to wear a helmet a car once kicked up a
rock that flew at my head luckily i was
wearing my scooter helmet got a
concussion wow see me and your mom think
you should wear a helmet everybody wear
a helmet the thing the thing for me is
uh i've never hit my head before
and i've been skating for 22 or 22 and a
half years or whatever
but uh recently i've been rollerblading
and with this i've been going up like
eight to nine feet on the on the vert
wall
and sometimes you lose your footing and
you get ejected and then you're coming
nine feet straight down to the ground
there was there was one really funny day
where i went up
and um it's a short vert wall with what
that means is
a good a good vertical quarter pipe has
like a foot of vert and it's big maybe
like 13 feet that gives you a chance to
pump up to it and actually ride the wall
before getting air we have a very short
one it's seven feet which means it stops
right at the point where it goes vert so
it's
it kind of sucks and so i went up it
with some good speed and i accidentally
kicked too hard off of the wall because
you either jump a little bit before the
vert or you wait till the vert and so i
got ejected what that means is you're
not on the wall anymore now you're just
nine feet in the air headed straight
down to flat ground and sideways so
you're gonna but uh i was able to
bend my my legs a little bit to get some
forward motion and roll out of it and i
was totally fine and then i didn't wear
a helmet then they're about two i'm
never wearing a helmet says tim there's
the trope of like the warrior king that
fights with his men for years and then
eventually they're like you have to go
back and stay in the capitol and we need
you alive and and
and smart because you're our leader we
can't risk your life anymore and i think
rogan might even give you the advice of
stop skating dude like he tells the
fighters stop fighting because his head
traumas those cts are like i never hit
my head before yeah of course before but
yeah
but but my point is
if you take brain damage you know that's
a big part of your career is your brain
sounds like a you problem what if that's
what
fighter buddies that are like have
careers in media like stop fighting but
what if tim starts wearing a helmet and
it throws off his balance and then he
becomes more prone to accidents
if you're not used to wearing one you
know when i was little it was really
distracting and it's like really
uncomfortable
but uh i don't i'm not really going ham
anymore and fighting's not skating it's
it's that but you know that i think the
risk of head trauma is a lot smaller
skating skating you want to weigh in as
a doctor over here
yeah what do you think don't don't take
punches to the face i
i would recommend against punches to the
face and other traumatic forces falling
down how do you what am i falling down
don't fall down it's dangerous out there
guys not falling
all right i don't know what this means
i'm gonna read it bruce maximus says hey
y'all i'd like to ask dr latipo whether
he has a any stance on the seemingly
artificial lack of seats in med school
i've heard anecdotally there are some 50
qualified applicants per seat cheers
going back to my science lab science bs
have you heard of that
i don't know if it's um you know if it's
if it's uh
sort of
uh contrived it is true i mean medical
school is ridiculous there are
so many applications for exceed people
end up going to medical school even kind
of out of the country because that's
where they get in and it seems to be a
problem that's only getting worse and
the medical school classes don't expand
at the they don't seem to expand at the
rate of applicants
but it's it's uh it's regulated
and
you want you know you can run into
issues so for example there are only so
many residency spots so if you have say
you double the number of medical
students well maybe half of them won't
have anywhere to train when they're done
when they're done with medical school so
it's a you know it's a bit of a
complicated issue
all right
hayden says prediction speculation fauci
retiring because of fear of republican
control of congress in january biden
will retire in december or january
harris will grant pardons to biden's
fauci and peter dashik newsome appointed
vp
it's a bold it's a bold speculation i
don't i don't think so
you know i'd i'd love to believe that
biden is going to resign or retire and
then something happens but it's just
i mean i think it's an emergency card
like if he really couldn't make it that
would make him resign but like i think
they're gonna try and make him get
through an entire first term i do think
a second term is very clearly off the
table
all right
let's grab some super chats
waffle sensei says tim do you ever spend
time watching yuri besmanov's long
lectures i think you'd appreciate them
most people just seen the 12-minute
interview but yuri does detailed
breakdowns of this stuff interesting we
should get that we'll play it i'm just
we we were supposed to have the
freedamastan studio built
like in march
it was like a year ago was supposed to
be done they got delayed and then the
framing is going up so they are building
it maybe in a week or two the structure
will be done then we got to do the
internals and it's like but i'm really
excited for this because we'll be able
to like put a big projector up and play
this and just have it running in the
background all day and cool stuff like
that so i'm very much excited for all
that that'll be great
all right bill hughes says fauci will be
retiring from the us government so he
can draw that humongous pension he's not
retiring from making money from research
there you go more money to be made he
can keep working somewhere else you know
what's probably going to happen
i think the real reason he's resigning
he's retiring or he's not retiring he's
resigning
is that
the pension but he's going to do book
tours
he's going to go on talk shows he's
gonna do contributor ships he's gonna
feel pretty for a little while people
wanting to interview him he's gonna go
to one of these networks and he's gonna
be like five million dollars and i will
be a contributor to your network and
then they're gonna sign the deal with
them and have them like he already does
this for free though right do you think
he has any political ambitions do you
think he'll try and parlay this into
like being elected somewhere he has 81
so bernie sanders might object
do you imagine if he ran for president
no i would really prefer he didn't that
would be funny
all right the old man time at media says
the presbyterian church is a liberal
church they are pro-choice and pro-l
lbgt interesting so the bombing there
are a lot of right wing or what there
are a lot of left-wing leaning churches
i mean i grew up episcopalian and the
episcopalian church just came out uh in
part in favor of uh gender
related treatments both surgical and
medical so i don't think that
necessarily clarifies anything i stand
by my
speculation that this was personal on
some level
no saint 317 says in 2019 a man attacked
kyoto animation studio he set fire to
the building and stabbed people as he
ran out killing 36 people
injured an additional 34 it doesn't take
much to cause havoc
so this the sad reality of life is that
it's really hard to build a machine and
it's really easy to disrupt one yeah i
think about that a lot yeah you can have
this beautiful massive machine of gears
i i think about this when you watch the
show like when you watch a show about
newspaper printing
be it like an old movie or whatever
and the machine is massive and all the
newspapers are being printed in full
speed and then someone takes a paper
clip into one gear then the whole thing
just shuts down it's just so crazy
life is delicate yup yup hard to build
easy to knock down man
eraftis of stet era says in the pale
moonlight tim stay safe i want to shout
him out because i mentioned that during
the show that's the star trek ds9
episode i i highly recommend
omg puppy says i don't think dugan and
putin have even met he advocates for a
multipolar world that preserves the
traditions of every civilization he
attacks fascism communism and liberalism
as 20th century failures interesting
devin garden says dugan was there when
the bomb went off i watched a video
yesterday of him looking at the burning
wreckage in shock and horror
yeah i saw the photos all over the place
the photo and the video
all right doug ripley says
general latipo
what is ron desantis like to work for
why would he make a good potus and who
else in your field would he recommend
and who else in your field would he
recommend go on irl
well he's i enjoy working for him and
frankly part of the reason is that it
feels more like i mean i i don't know
that i've ever felt like i'm working for
him i feel like i'm working with him so
that's that's been fun i mean it's been
it's been fun
he doesn't try and sort of manage or
micromanage
he's really about getting the job done
that's just his focus is the outcome and
and not sort of the
kind of the
the political stuff that seems to you
know that mostly dominates politics in
terms of
how how politicians
carry themselves and what they do so
it's been a lot of fun working with him
i mean i i think he
he is
like i said he cares about the outcome
and it would be great to have someone
it's great to have him and that's why
he's been so successful in florida is
that he actually cares about the outcome
and doesn't care what people are gonna
think about uh you know unpopular
opinions or names they're gonna call him
and things like that those are great
qualities and those are really great
qualities for a leader right on notre
dame says the bombing is similar to the
ira they believed the british were
occupying ireland and after much
escalation it resulted in car bombings
in london
in london man that's crazy
yeah i've been to uh northern ireland
i've never been to
the
uh to dublin or you know i guess would
you call just ireland northern ireland
the regular part regular ireland the
ireland regular island yeah just uh just
uh belfast
beautiful great place
crazy seeing all the stuff man
all right aj cook says dude you need to
turn on notifications for rwa on twitter
russian government has already released
a video of a suspect
hot blonde what is this
not scraggly bearded dude interesting
a hot blonde
german ideology girl
i'll take a look at it in
feminism second i love it it could have
been german person that's what i was
thinking earlier in the show but i'm
like i'm not gonna start naming
countries that's too you know that's
ridiculous
new t2 says
chicken ian is the best we love him
well all right yeah he is
what do we got here he's the best
chicken
the best chicken the greatest chicken
the mala mama says a division of the
presbyterian church is progressive
within realm of reason for unstable
manga person to target don't know how
why if connected to federal building
i don't know why that one is far away
and there are other liberal churches
much closer liberal churches i mean
churches that have liberal factionism
like i said there's an episcopalian
church within close proximity
you have to like you'd have to look at
the map but like if the federal building
is close to let's call like a center of
town and there are 10 churches close by
there you have to travel
20 minutes on foot three minutes by car
to this other church
again that feels more
uh pointed it feels more specific it
could be because of ideology i'm not
saying that but it does feel
like if you were against churches that
had left-leaning ideology you could have
picked one closer to the other place and
made a faster escape
noah zork says tim tay pronouns that's
actually t tim tims okay it's t tim tims
yeah what's going on my pronouns oh t
tim tims that's right my my name is
actually a pronoun is it
t-m-apostrophe s yes the funny thing
about pronouns is like we use pronouns
as
generic placeholder words
so we don't say your name over and over
again but if everyone has their own then
we might just call you by your name yeah
what's the point i i find myself
thinking about when i'm reporting on
people you have to be like okay what
what names am i using i think it'll just
be safer to use their name but i do
wonder how long until we all start
talking a third person to just avoid all
pronouns in any case at all that way
there's no question yeah and you i would
just say hannah claire says that this
would be interesting and it would be
horrible i don't know like talking this
way as a joke that world is not coming
what happens when there's two ian's in
the same room
says this is certainly does not it's
like when you're in elementary school it
has to be like uh e and c and e and t
and you know fight it out
uh are you uh
why do you say it's not coming are you
are you personally involved in the fight
against pronoun and third person speech
i mean i guess in in some ways yeah no i
mean you know it's it's it's uh
you know some of these some of these um
kind of agendas they start in one place
but they're really headed somewhere else
and that's a that's an example of one
what if i made my pronoun we
so you can make your pronouns anything
we're gonna go to the park we're gonna
go have some food
like stop bringing me into this like
speaking that way people feel obligated
to go with you like we're going to the
grocery store we're like okay yeah i
guess so i guess we're all going we're
gonna relax power suggestions yeah we
are yeah we're gonna have a chill night
play some across the obelisk and then
when someone invites themselves with you
you say what are you doing yeah why are
you following me to invite you here are
you following us we didn't invite you
here yeah stop being confused
all right fiend v
for joe what is your take on the florida
medical marijuana program and possible
legalization in the future if you can
speak on it
well
it's it's interesting i mean so
i in general
favor people you know being able to use
marijuana if they want
but i wouldn't want my kids to use it
and it's not uh the risk-free medicaid
sort of drug that it was portrayed at
portrayed as initially so i don't know
if you guys saw these articles so the
new york times washington post they were
all big pushers of legalization of
marijuana but just recently new york
times has run multiple negative articles
about it i don't know if you saw those
but basically oh yeah in young people so
they've run
you know very prominent articles about
how you know some individuals kind of
develop mental illness other harms
something called hyperemesis syndrome
that that we see not infrequently in the
hospital so sort of people that use it
chronically they go crazy they come
start throwing up they they can they
vomit they develop abdominal pain and
it's kind of unstoppable
uh it's it you know they require
hospitalizations it's very severe and
there are other harms associated with it
in addition
really high quality studies have looked
at the association of legalization with
things like car accidents
and and they found a an association so
in other words you know the implication
is that people are using it and driving
and you know and unfortunately injuring
themselves injuring other people having
car accidents clinical study or an
observation these are these are um
they're observational studies they're
not all wrong right multiple studies
have shown have found similar findings
so the new york times is finally is now
acknowledging harms you know you can
look it up they've written they've
published a few recent articles they're
very negative on their using kids it's
totally harmful for kids not good for
your brain so
medically i think it absolutely should
be available for individuals certainly
people with pain and there can be a lot
of challenging things but people should
realize it's not like some harmless
thing i mean it's potentially very
harmful i didn't touch it till i was 23
and i feel like i dodged a bullet
because as a kid i a lot of the kids i
knew that did it in high school were
just had a hard hard time paying
attention in school basically their
minds you know your intelligence goes
down your wisdom might go up but it's
like
you really got to love what you're
paying attention to if you're going
that's like this your wisdom's not going
up if your intelligence is going down
no that i think that's actually an
interesting point i i i agree with that
actually like
wisdom is
how would you define wisdom what's the
what's the best way to do it knowing
that you what you think you know might
be wrong
sort of i mean
the the saying is that uh intelligence
is knowing that or was it knowledge is
knowing that a tomato is a fruit and
wisdom is knowing not to put in a fruit
salad
no i hear i hear you i mean i would say
i would you know to get a little bit
kind of um
uh
i don't know more medical and
psychological on this right so if you
take a drug that reduces your
inhibitions that reduces your attachment
to sort of held beliefs that you have
other beliefs that you know that may not
be true that may be false or maybe very
rigid and usually rigid beliefs aren't
they're usually there's usually
something behind them that's um that's
not authentic when when individuals have
sort of rigid beliefs about things so
when you when you take those away
your sort of clarity i could see you
know your
your ability to identify
a belief that is more in line with who
you might be
or what is you know closer to some
you know some truth or
or more or insight that can increase but
that's a funky way to say that you're
you can't i don't know i'm like i'm
thinking about this whole wisdom thing
that's i'm not that's not the path to
wisdom i mean the path to wisdom ought
not to be so maybe meditation and
studies it's costly the internet says
intelligence can be defined as the
ability to acquire and apply information
while wisdom on your hand is wait hold
on uh intelligence is simply having
knowledge and wisdom is the ability to
apply the knowledge that you have so
yeah maybe so you're able to apply
things better like like sam harris i
think you said he's he's all knowledge
and no wisdom not not that extreme but
yeah he's got a deficit in wisdom at
least he's portrayed
no intelligence or wisdom at all it's
not
really interesting things or recite
studies or do math in their head but
like if you drop them in the middle of
anywhere they would not be able to find
their way home because they have no
common sense or they're just not able to
use the knowledge that they have to
make make their life go forward i guess
i found with uh with weed and meditation
it's a good combo because when i would
smoke it would be i would get my my
thoughts would race so it was more
challenging to meditate and when i could
if i could do it with thc in my system i
was way easier to do it without it all
of a sudden
all right brian cooper says fifth paid
comment will you read it y'all are
against gender surgeries yet y'all
remain quiet about circumcision in fact
you endorse judaism tim i don't remember
ever specifically endorsing judaism like
that sounds very strong
i will also mention we haven't had any
news stories about the prominence of
political controversy running
circumcision but uh i'm against it oh
really i just it happened to me but i
mean i don't know what do you what are
your what's your experience with
circumcision do you think of it as like
mutilation i mean your medical doctor
you know it's interesting so and there
are some areas that i've yeah i'm the
father of three boys so there's some
areas that that i've studied sort of
more more deeply in and some that i
haven't i just want to add one more
thing about marijuana so there's an old
paper in a in a
and i think the journal science or cell
that basically exposes
um
brain cells to a few different chemicals
ketamine's one of them i think thc is
another one anyway these chemicals are
neurotoxic so that's just i mean just to
kind of kind of keep that in mind too
again things that aren't really
discussed but um but
stuff that's not great for brain cells
with circumcisions it's interesting i
have not i know that there are
individuals that feel very strongly that
that it's harmful to the development of
of babies
it's definitely painful there's you know
there's no question about that
on the other side it reduces there's
pretty good research that shows that it
reduces the risk of of sexually
transmitted illnesses when you know when
kids get people get older so does
marriage so that also reduces it and
abstinence also reduces it and while
we're talking about well i mean i just i
think it's interesting you know
i don't i don't see that as a i i
understand it to be true i just don't
see it as an argument for the practice
like well when he's older he can sleep
around you know what i mean yeah i don't
either i mean
i think this is kind of a uniquely
american debate because we have a blend
of cultures in america whereas like if
you are
european like all both my parents are
european decided immigrants you know
it's not a question because culturally
it's not as normal for them i remember
my parents like having this telling me
they would have these discussions with
their friends and being like
they had never even crossed their mind
to get a child circumcised because it's
just culturally not normal i've got this
theory that it's when it happens it
exposes the nerves at the end of the
penis basically you know and then makes
people more sensitive to sex and then
more aggressive it's it
actually cuts like half the nerves are
you saying that this is where the
testosterone is going
i i don't know i think it might make
people more aggressive in later life
because of that it's like a it's like a
sensitive trauma that they deal with but
you're saying it actually diminishes
sensitivity i don't know it's just a
theory it cuts the nerves off
all right raymond g stanley jr says
wisdom is not fighting an alligator
underwater
that's right
but what is wisdom is not yes you have
what is i like that that wisdom is the
application of knowledge
if you can but the process
if you don't have high intelligence you
get the knowledge wrong and then you
apply it properly but you got the wrong
piece
corn says rip emmy ian can i get some of
your love for my brother luke for the
loss of his chocolate lab she was a
great dog yeah luke you got this
today's gonna be really good
you guys all of that you know i say
about losing a dog is all that pain
you're feeling is all of the love for
your dog being expressed all at one time
and you're gonna remember that feeling
forever
so it's it's a good thing if you didn't
feel that way when your dog passed it
would mean that your dog wasn't you know
wasn't that important that feeling is
like all of that love and every
everything just coming together at that
one moment
so it's uh it's it's it's a beautiful
sadness right
yeah would you you know the question is
when you think about it like pain it's
like oh okay
think about it this way we can make all
that pain go away just never have had
the dog how does that sound and it's
like no absolutely not of course right
the pain of your dog passing it sucks
because your dog is passing but it's
it's a good expression
it's it's it's like
all the goodness is here you can feel it
all at once
better to have loved and lost than never
loved at all yeah
all right kevin clark says is tim trying
to say his t levels are too high to
worry about a helmet or is the lack of a
helmet supposed to raise his t levels
both
i wear half a helmet on one side of my
head
that way if i fall on one side i get
lucky on the other side i die
thank you i love the gamble
you know i only really wear it now when
i'm going on the vert wall it's like
again not the biggest wall it's just
it's seven so it's a seven foot vertical
transition but if i'm like eight or nine
feet up
and i'm looking down
most of the time 99.9 the time it's just
you're fine you fall you slide or
whatever i don't have knee pads on
either though but you know whatever
wear a helmet when you're going way up
there
chase lindsay says hey tim james shaw is
running for commissioner of agriculture
in florida he's an organic farmer and 2a
supporter running against an
establishment politician p.s did you get
salty cracker on the show
perhaps we should perhaps we should
florida primaries are tomorrow same with
new york really
oh that'll be interesting
trump endorsed some of those uh new york
democrats be interested to see if they
can pull off a victory with his
endorsement make him proud what if what
they're going to win and then trump's
going to be like my endorsements are now
see how great they are yeah like i'll
get them right
well you like endorse nader
garnett says lex friedman got a kgb
defector who became an american
he counters yuri besmanov because yuri
was in india not in the u.s get that guy
in the show from lex oh that'd be
interesting
all right let's see we'll grab one more
here from waffle sensei says wisdom is
animal handling insight medicine
perception survival and whatever else
the dm allows you to add your
proficiency bonus too
yeah i think bluff might be a wisdom
check as well you can tell when
someone's lying and you can lie yourself
ladies and gentlemen if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and head over
to timcast.com
we're going to have an amazing members
only show we're going to talk about
florida's policies covid vaccines and
things like that so again go to
timcast.com sign up you can follow the
show at timcast irl you can follow me at
timcast joe do you want to shout
anything out i hear you got a book yeah
i do i do
i've written a book it actually comes
out tomorrow tim called transcend fear
and it's about um
it's about
you know
just really briefly personally for me
you know i i i
am almost it's it's like a miracle that
i'm in the position that i'm in
and um and it it started with a
traumatic event that i had when i was a
kid
and long consequences of that that went
on for years
until i fell in love with my wife and
had to actually sort of face them
because one of the things about love all
of us you know many of us have exp have
different types of traumatic events in
our past and um on all of us experience
daily stress and all of these things
affect how we show up in the world
and um and for me when i fell in love
with my wife it was um it was a sort of
like a volcano
erupting
because one of the things about love is
that it forces things to the surface
and so the things that don't work in
your life well if you fall in love you
can't kind of you can't just kind of
keep them in the closet
and that's led to
you know sort of a journey with my wife
where i was driving her nuts and she
referred me to different people and i
finally met a guy named christopher
mayher who's a former navy seal and he
used um
techniques from chinese medicine stuff
related to meridians
stuff related to chi and the flow of
energy
things that like and what that
translated into is kind of physical
manipulations verbal stuff lots of
different things
and i experienced
a
you know priceless transformation that
let me
basically let me do what i did in terms
of the communication the thinking the
clear thinking other things that led to
what i'm doing now and will lead to who
knows what heaven knows what next but
you know but that's really the core of
the book i talk about kind of leadership
and making decisions under uncertainty
and kind of how
why decisions were wrong and should have
been recognized as being wrong at the
time they were made and how
leaders can avoid making
similar
blunders that are you know quite costly
in the future so that's the book it's
called transcend fear
um tim's gonna put it up on the uh you
know on the internet thing um you can
tell that i'm a real where do you get
your book
you can get it from
the evil amazon uh or i think barnes and
nobles and i don't know
the less evil barnes and noble yeah
right the and the slightly less
evil but yeah yeah that's right right on
yeah we'll we'll put it in the clips
when you know cool so people can have
the link because
you said right yeah yeah that sounds
good yeah that's awesome i definitely
want to read that i'm hannah claire
brimlow i'm a writer for timcastcut.com
i think you should check it out every
day it's a great place to get all of
your news or at least some of it uh i'm
also on pop culture crisis tomorrow at 3
p.m with brett and mary so come there
and see me talk about things that are
not politics or at least adjacent to
politics um and you can check me out on
instagram at hannah claire.b
uh you guys follow me on the internet
anywhere you want to at ian cross and
you find me all over the place hit me up
there and i'll talk to you soon
and i'm chris thanks for watching
thanks for hanging out everybody make
sure you check out this members only
show over at timcast.com we're gonna be
recording it right now it should be
around 11 and this one should get really
interesting so thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all then
you